- So did anyone serve a mission?
- I served in Finland.
- Can I hear something in Finnish?
(speaks in Finnish)
- Yeah, mine was hello,
I'm a missionary of the church
(group laughs)
of Jesus Christ of Latter Day Saints.
(upbeat music)
- [Host] We brought
together seven Mormons,
or Latter Day Saints.
- I'm a member.
- I am a member.
- I'm a member,
- of the church
- of Jesus Christ
- of Latter Day Saints.
- [Host] One of them is a liar.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll split a cash prize.
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
(cash register pings)
Who is the odd one out?
- I guess we can start with like,
how long everyone's been
a member of the church.
Does that work?
- [All] Yeah, sure.
- Born and raised.
- I'm Zaliah by the way,
or you can call me Z.
I actually converted to the
church when I was 10 years old.
I converted before my mom actually,
I got baptized before her.
So I guess like eight years now.
- I'm Savannah, I was born and raised
in the church too.
- Yeah, I'm Elizabeth born
and raised in the church.
- Haydn, also born and raised
(group laughing)
- I'm Caleb, I was born and raised,
but if you wanna know how long that is
since I was baptized, 19 years.
- And I'm Natalie and I was also born
and raised in the church.
(group laughs)
- Bad start already, oh no!
- I think the main thing I was looking for
was someone who just had
knowledge about the church.
- Well, I think something
we could do quick
is like just say a scripture
we like and why we like it.
- Okay.
- So I could start, I
mean, I like Moroni 7:37.
That was my missionary plaque.
I don't have a memorized,
but it basically says that
it's by faith, that miracles are wrought.
and if miracles have ceased
it's cuz of unbelief.
So I like that cuz it's helped reassure me
that miracles do happen.
- I don't know what exact verse it is,
that already makes me look really bad.
I think it's like Nephi 12
or somewhere around there.
Just cuz I had an amazing
experience when I read it
but it was like the last
verse of the chapter
and he basically is saying,
oh what is he saying?
It's just like, know that
when you read these things,
these are true.
- There are quite a few
books in the Book of Mormon
and she didn't mention one specifically,
she mentioned a grouping of books.
- That makes me sound bad
because mine is like a
scripture mastery one,
but I don't remember where it's from.
It's like, 'Thou shall not let your light
shine under a bushel.'
- Oh that's in Matthew.
- It's Matthew! Yes, yes.
And I learned that in high school
and I was living in Oregon
and so I was one of the only Mormons there
and it just made me have
to be like, I don't know,
I had to be an example
to everyone else as a
Mormon at the time, so
(timer buzzes)
(upbeat music plays)
- So Natalie kept saying the word Mormon
without even flinching.
In our church, there's a big push
that Mormon is not our official name.
- I voted for Savanna because
of the scripture mistake
(error sound buzzes)
- [Natalie] (whispered) Oh, bye, Savannah.
- I just had a feeling I
was gonna be eliminated
because I definitely had a brain freeze
and I just froze.
- [Elizabeth] So did
anyone serve a mission?
- I served in Italy.
- I served in Finland.
- Wow.
(Group scoffs)
- Very fun.
(Group laughs)
- Can I hear something, is it Finnish?
(speaks in Finnish)
- Wow.
- All right, I guess I'm up.
(speaks in Italian)
- Yeah, mine was hello,
I'm a missionary of the church
(group laughs)
of Jesus Christ of Latter Day Saints.
- How about what was everyone's
favorite conference talk from last week?
- I did watch some of the
Prophet's messages for seminary,
but I didn't watch the whole thing.
- That's fair.
- It was my birthday weekend.
- That's so fair.
- Sorry.
- Every six months in October and April,
there is something called
general conference.
The first presidency of our church
and other leaders will
have different talks given.
And so it's important that you know,
people tune in to see
what the Lord has to say.
A big part of the LDS religion
is that we do believe that there
is a living Prophet on
the earth right now.
- I always like Elder Holland's talks
about mental health awareness.
- Yeah, exactly.
- and how we can better ourselves
and be aware of what other
people are going through.
- Yeah. I love when he talks about that,
cause I suffer from
mental health issues, so.
- Yeah, I love that
there's been so many talks
recently about mental health.
Like, I feel like that's so important
and I'm glad that it's not like,
it's being de-stigmatized I think.
- So you guys all were
raised right? Mormon.
And do you feel like or part of
the Church of Jesus Christ
of Latter Day Saints
(group laughs)
- My seminary teacher
is gonna scream at me
when he hears me say that I said that.
- It's a hard transition.
- Yeah, sorry. It's a long-winded one,
but do you guys feel like you were raised
like pretty much with
very, very set values
or do you feel like your
values really like are
in line with the values of the church?
- So I don't know if
you guys have noticed,
but I have a tattoo and
I have extra piercings.
I, yeah, (laughs)
- Me too
- When I was younger, I went
through a more rebellious phase
because a lot of my, some of my values
weren't aligning with the church
and I feel like I have a
really strong testimony in the Savior
and I was like, as long
as I still have that,
I think I'll be okay.
- And like
- So like, You left and then
or not left, but you kind of
strayed and then came back.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I went in active for
a little bit you know,
I did some soul searching and
- I get, I'm kind of actually
in more of a inactive phase
right now in my, kind of in my path.
So like, or I'm kind of, you know
I'm kind of doing that soul searching
right now.
(timer buzzes)
- It's always important
to ask questions for sure.
- Absolutely.
- Oh, Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- She was inactive for
a little bit previously.
That was a little suspicious.
- [Host] We actually have a three way tie!
The tie is between Natalie,
- (Natalie laughs) Okay.
- [Host] Elizabeth, and Z.
You each will have 30 seconds
just kinda state your case.
- Well, I don't really know what to say.
I was born and raised in the church.
Favorite movie's the R.M.
(group laughs)
So that's like, a little
bit part of Mormon culture.
If you know that, I don't
know what to say, that
(Natalie laughs nervously)
I teach youth 15 year old Sunday school.
(timer buzzes)
- So I feel like, I
would've hidden my tattoos
and I would've taken out all my piercings,
if I were trying to blend
in, if I were the mole.
I was baptized at eight,
my brother's been sealed in the temple,
I do baptisms for the dead a lot.
I have a temple recommend
currently right now.
(timer buzzes)
- Best way I could state my case is
by reciting the young woman's theme.
"We are daughter's of our Heavenly Father,
who loves us, and we love him.
We will stand as witnesses God
at all times and in all
things and in all places
as we strive to live
the young woman's values
which are faith, divine
nature, individual worth,
knowledge, choice and accountability,
good works, integrity, virtue.
We believe as we come to and
accept act upon these values,
we will be prepared to
strengthen and home and family,
make and keep sacred covenant,
and receive the ordinances of the temple,
and enjoy the blessings exaltation."
(timer buzzes)
(upbeat music plays)
(error sound buzzes)
- Sorry.
- [Group Member] Oh, no
(group laughs)
- [Host] Raise your hand if you think
the mole is still in the box
and you would like to continue the game.
- I have so many things
I want to talk about.
- I feel, Yeah, I feel like
there's only two people
that have gone out so far.
- I'm happy to keep talking.
I don't know, I don't know
(overlapping chatter)
- Yeah, I got no problem that.
- To help educate our audience.
(group laughs)
Here's a question I been wanted to ask
that will continue the
conversation we had.
I was just wondering if anyone
could share a moment they had that really
helped them come to know
these things are true.
- My grandpa passed away
four years ago this month.
And he was actually my
last living grandparent.
There was a time where I
was praying for strength,
you know after it happened,
and I just got the best feeling of
just warmth of like, I'm
going to see him again.
- Personally, I think I already said this,
but I was the first person
to actually get baptized
in my church, and I was only 10 years old.
It was really, really signifying.
It's not even the feelings that you feel.
It's like literally the changes you see.
My family was always
loud, super rambunctious.
There was never peace in the home.
And then as soon as I started
bringing back these lessons
and teachings, I learned, all of a sudden
the family was super peaceful
and it was super nice.
Can I ask you guys more about, well,
you said you're currently going through
kind of an inactive period.
- Yeah
- And you said you went
through one already.
- Yeah.
- Do you guys wanna go
a little more in depth about that or
just kind of like the questions you had?
- So, for me, a lot of it
had to do with, you know
cause I consider myself to
be left-leaning politically.
And so a lot of that, you
know, doesn't really align
with some of the things
the church teaches.
And so for me, it was just kind of
finding a way that I can
still hold my beliefs.
Cause I do think it's important that we
treat everyone with love
and being able to separate
I can vote how I want
and that doesn't indicate
my faith in the gospel.
- Mine's kind of personal right now,
and I'm just kinda
trying to figure it out.
You know, like what
- I understand
- I think my focus is
had just kind of changed.
- I think if you go through
a period of inactivity
you can really see the difference between
when you're living the
gospel and when you're not.
And I found my life to be
better when I was living it.
And so I think that was a
very important experience
to me to get my own testimony.
(timer buzzes)
(upbeat music plays)
- Still a little bit
suspicious of Clay, you know,
his period of inactivity,
which I know sounds kind
of hypocritical of me.
(error sound buzzes)
- [Elizabeth] Bye, Clay.
- [Clay] Bye, guys.
- Bye, Clay.
- I wasn't surprised.
I had a feeling I was gonna
get eliminated the entire game.
- [Host] Raise your hand
if you think the mole is still in the box
and you'd wish to
continue playing the game.
If the lights turn green,
that means you have voted
the mole out and you all win.
(intense music plays)
If the lights turn red,
that means the mole is
still in a box and you lose.
(group cheers)
- Oh, good!
- Everybody suspicious is gone.
- [Host] Will the mole
reveal themselves in 3, 2, 1.
- I knew it.
- I knew it too!
- I voted for you every round.
(group chatters)
I had my suspicions from the start.
You kept saying Mormon
over and over again,
- I thought that too,
- [Caleb] Without flinching.
- And so I was one of
the only Mormon's there,
little bit part of Mormon culture.
I started to have doubts about the church
before I went to college
and I eventually was like,
Hmm, something's not adding
up between what I'm saying
and what I'm actually feeling.
I'm very left-leaning politically.
And then once I was out of the church,
I realized, oh, I'm gay.
I couldn't even think about it when I was
a member of the church because it was just
so out of the possibility in my head.
But now I'm happy.
- Right
- I live in California.
If you are LGBT and in
the church, you are loved.
There is a place for you,
No matter if it's in the
church or out of the church.
You can do whatever you want to do,
and whatever you need to
do that is best for you.
- I'm really glad to have this opportunity
and to talk about my
experiences with the church.
And I really am glad that
people can watch this
and listen to our stories.
I think that we all had some really,
really good thoughts shared.
- Members of our church really do try
to live in the Savior's way,
and I think as we do that,
hopefully we can become more like him.
And I think as we grow as people,
hopefully we'll be able
to show other people
that we really do love
them for who they are.
(group exclaiming)
- [Hadyn] I think we have to,
I think we have to
- [Z] Thank you.
- Oh, he's shoving it in his pocket.
(Elizabeth laughs)
- [Z] I think we have to
(group laughs)
(group talks indistinctly)
I was like, oh my gosh.
- Oh wait, I got pockets in the back too.
- [Z] Oh my gosh.